[Music]
foreign
do you need to maintain a consistent
security posture across your
internet-facing applications but also
want the flexibility to tweak specific
requirements for certain applications
welcome back to our go deep with Cloud
Armor Series where we do demonstrations
on capabilities and features so you
learn what's available how to use it and
how you can leverage it in your
environment
in our previous video we covered the
basics about Cloud armor and the
architecture we'll be basing our
demonstrations on if you're thinking
what previous video check out the link
in the description and go watch that
first because it has helpful context
that you'll need
Cloud Armor's flexible and efficient
policy configuration capabilities allow
you to have a uniform strategy across
applications while maintaining the
flexibility to create custom rule sets
with your specific requirements and
modify policies when needed in this
video we'll be going over how to
configure Cloud armor rules and policies
to secure your applications
we'll cover how to create a new rule
from scratch how to clone an existing
out-of-the-box Rule and modify it to
create a new rule how to copy a rule or
policy and apply it to multiple backends
we'll also highlight our rate limiting
feature here and how to use a rule in
preview mode and test a new rule before
enabling it and we'll cover how to use
the threat intelligence feature here
check out the description for the timing
of each of these so you can go to
whichever one you want at any point to
configure Cloud armor your ID requires
the compute Network admin and compute
security admin roles you'll want to
ensure those are in place before you
start working with rules we'll be doing
all of these demonstrations in the cloud
console and Google Cloud command line
interface
for our first demonstration we'll be
showing how to create a rule from
scratch
before we start let's take a look at the
page we're trying to block
you can see that the page can be opened
because we have not yet deployed any of
the rules we're about to configure now
back in our console we'll start by
clicking into the test policy that we're
going to execute on
and click the add rule button
in the description box I'll write the
rule itself
in this case we're going to block U.S
users that are using a specific header
then I can click into advanced mode
we're using common expression language
to write our match condition common
expression language or cell is used in
many places in Google Cloud
in this particular case we're using a
compound rule
our action is denied
and I'm going to assign a priority level
of 12 000.
the way rules are evaluated within Cloud
armor is from lowest to highest the
first rule that matches wins the action
specified in that rule is taken and no
further rules are examined so rule
priority matters
I add this rule into our setup and it'll
take a moment to show up on the screen
we can see here that the new rule has
been deployed
now in my browser I'll make a request to
my application
but before making the request I'll use
the browser plugin called mod headers to
insert a header before the browser makes
a request to my application
the plugin will add the header user
agent hacker to the requests made by the
browser
you can see that the request was denied
with an HTTP 403 response and that's it
for our very first rule configuration
very simple and easy to complete
the next configuration we'll cover is
how to use an existing out of the box
Rule and modify it to create a new rule
we start by clicking the add rule button
and for this scenario we're using cell
rules again
we'll use the O wasp mod security rule
for PHP and modify it slightly
again in advanced mode paste in our cell
expression to block requests with a PHP
vulnerability
here we're using the PHP rule set but
we're also incorporating a compound rule
where we target a user agent
the action is denied
and the priority is eleven thousand
click add to deploy the rule
and you can see that the rule has
populated into our rule set and is ready
to go
now in my Chrome browser I'll stimulate
a request that matches the condition for
the PHP owasp rule set
my mod header browser plugin already has
the header user agent hacker which will
be added to the request made by the
browser
then I regenerate the request
and you can see it fails as expected
because in the PHP oasp rule we were
explicitly looking to block the user
agent field contained the value hacker
next we can go into Cloud logging and
review the cloud armor Lots
here are the log lines that show the
action taken by Cloud armor
you can see under Json payload and
enforce security policy the rule that
was applied and details like the
priority of the rule
using Cloud logging you have real-time
insights into how Cloud armor is
operating you have the ability to
analyze if when and why a specific
request was allowed or denied
the extra level of details gives you
confidence and also helps in identifying
any false positives during rule tuning
next we'll demonstrate how simple it is
to copy a rule or policy and apply it to
multiple backends
we can use the export function to create
a yaml file containing the entire
configuration for a policy
for this I'll open Google Cloud shell
and execute the export command to create
the yaml file
we can now use the yaml file to create
an exact copy of the policy
to create the new policy we execute this
command
if I refresh my page
I can now see that my new policy has
been created and if I click into it
I see that it's an exact clone of what
we previously had with our app one
policy but this is for app2
now that we've copied the policy we'll
show how to apply it to multiple
backends
go to the policy
and switch to the Target tab
click on ADD policy to new Target
and select the new backend
note that a policy can be applied to
multiple backends but a backend can only
be attached to a single policy
let's add to this example the use of the
rate limiting capability
rate base rules help you protect your
applications from a large volume of
requests that flood your instances and
block access for legitimate users
rate limiting can be used to achieve two
main objectives one prevent any
particular client from exhausting
application resources and two protect
your application instances from erratic
and unpredictable spikes in the rate of
client requests Google Cloud armor has
two types of raid-based rules first
throttle you can enforce a maximum
request limit per client or across all
clients by throttling individual clients
to a user-configured threshold second
rate based ban you can rate limit
requests that match a rule on a per
client basis and then temporarily ban
those clients for a configured period of
time if they exceed a user configured
threshold
we identify individual clients for rate
limiting by using the following key
types for aggregating requests and
enforcing rate limits all a single key
for all clients IP a unique key for each
client Source IP address
HTTP header a unique key for each unique
HTTP header value
xffip a unique key for each original
Source IP address of the client that is
the first IP address in the list of ips
specified in the x-forwarded for HTTP
header and HTTP cookie a unique key for
each HTTP cookie value so now let's
configure a rate based ban I'll be using
the Google Cloud shell again and I'll
paste my command to create this rule
in this rate limit rule you can see that
the action is rate based ban we're
setting the limit on the request to 10
and the time interval to 60 seconds so
if we receive more than 10 requests in a
minute from the same IP the user will be
banned for 300 seconds
you can always go into the policy and
confirm that the rule has been created
I have a separate setup running in the
background to generate a large number of
requests
let's look into the logs to validate
that the rules taking effect and
exercising a rate based ban
as you can see from this log line the
rules preventing a user behind a single
IP from exhausting my application
resources
finally we'll show how to use a rule in
preview mode this allows us to test a
new rule before enabling it and make
sure there are no false positives which
is when a rule blocks requests it's not
supposed to
the action here is neither block nor
allow it's preview
you still put the action in the rule but
because it's in preview it will tell you
if it would have matched the rule but
ultimately ignore the behavior and
continue on to the next rule
this allows you to evaluate the
potential impact of a capability with
preview mode before actually blocking
traffic
for this demonstration we'll incorporate
the use of our threat intelligence
feature
Google Cloud armor threat intelligence
lets you secure your traffic by allowing
or blocking traffic to your external
https and TCP and SSL proxy load
balancers based on several categories of
threat intelligence data threat
intelligence data is obtained from both
primary and trusted third-party sources
Google creates and automatically updates
these lists of IP addresses as regularly
so all you need to do is to call the
list as an object in a rule and you'll
always be getting the latest threat
intelligence and force in that rule
there are different types of threat
Intel objects that you can use in a rule
some you'll likely want to block like
tour exit nodes and known malicious IP
addresses and some you might like to
allow like search engine crawlers public
Cloud providers and Upstream providers
like CDN providers now we'll create a
rule using a threat intelligence list
object this rule will deny requests from
the IP addresses of Tor exit nodes which
points at which traffic exits the Tor
Network
again in advance mode
paste in our cell expression check out
the link in the description for
information on creating these custom
language rules
we'll set the priority to ten thousand
action to deny
and enable preview mode
you can see that the rule has been
created
now I'll make a request from the Tor
Browser which is connected to the torn
Network
you can see that my request wasn't
denied because the rule is in preview
mode
now I'm going to go back to the rule and
turn preview mode off
then set the rule to deny and retry the
same request
we can see that the request was denied
let's get into Cloud logging and
validate both these scenarios we're
locked
you can see that when in preview mode we
let the request through but logged this
action
when we denied the request you can see
that being logged as well
Cloud logging is a great way for
security teams to verify Cloud armor is
working as they expect it to
and that's it that is how simple
configuring rules and policies in Google
Cloud armor is when it comes to web
application security it's important to
have a consistent strategy across
applications to maintain a certain level
of security with Cloud armor you have
this consistent security without having
to compromise on application specific
details now you can take these
principles and apply them to secure your
application to get started with Cloud
armor you can go to the console and find
it in the menu bar under network
security or you can type in Cloud armor
in the search bar make sure to check out
the links in the description for helpful
information and if you found the
demonstrations in this video helpful
make sure to subscribe so you don't miss
the upcoming videos in the go deep with
Google Cloud Armor Series
[Music]
thank you